there is no
turning back that's how politico
reported it people are starting to rise
up in cuba
the police are not happy with it the
regime is not happy with it
there's some pretty crazy witness
reports coming out that people are being
beaten and disappeared and it's hard to
know exactly what's happening
when the country is silencing people and
shutting down the internet so
we need to talk about this why well in
the united states we have the rise of
black lives matter i'm sure there are
many people who are
democrats or leftists who absolutely
love and will defend black lives matter
tribalistically
but you take a look at the things they
support what do they support the cuban
regime they support castro they
they um issued this tweet saying rest in
power fidel castro
they're very much communist and right
now even ocasio-cortez
is defending what the what the
government of cuba is doing to their
people
and it's scary scary to realize that if
we don't pay attention to what is
happening in our own country
we might end up suffering the same fate
as many of those in cuba who are trying
to fight against this
communist regime so we're going to talk
about it and today's going to be a bit
more conversational because we've got
some excellent guests
we've got ricardo lamas who is an mma
fighter who runs a ufc gym
and you're also an activist for cuban
freedom and then we have your dad
jose lomas who was actually an
anti-castro
a member of the underground movement
against castro in the 1960s in cuba
he's going to tell us all about uh you
know what he went through what's
happening now and uh what we can do what
anyone can do to help cuba but i will
mention one quick thing
just as an aside we actually had to deal
with some of
the the communism here in america
because they have some shirts they
wanted to share but we we had a
conversation
about it i don't think anybody was happy
couldn't show them we'll show them on
the after show though
and it's because youtube would probably
delete this show if we if we showed the
activist t-shirts that they had prepared
so
but we will show them for uh the members
only show so do you guys want to just do
a quick
quick introduction for yourselves jose
or ricardo
yeah pop go ahead you start okay my name
is jose lamas
i am a q1 citizen still today
i was a very happy kid in cuba
i hope someday cubans
that are born there
could enjoy the the
the many things that as a child are
enjoying cuba
especially being able to think to
explore
to be free to do things that that nobody
will tell me about it
to join the copper scouts
to be a boy scout with a promise of
being always ready to serve
and that is my dream that some day cuban
kids
will be born with my same opportunity
you were born in a democratic cuba yes
in 1940
when the 1940 constitution was born i
was born
right there and maybe because of that i
have
always thought about the ruling of our
constitution
that was a very advanced constitution
actually many people consider the 1940
constitution to be too much
progressive all political parties in
cuba
participated in the drafting of that
1940 constitution including the
socialist party of cuba
at that time was not known as the
communist party which is the only par in
cuba for the
for the since the revolution took over
and uh so i i
i believe that the return
to freedom in cuba and liberty has to be
based
on on that last constitution that fidel
when attacked the moncada barracks said
that he wanted to establish to to to
bring back
which he never did he ruled the country
without constitution
without any constitution for 17 years
let's uh we'll get into all that uh you
know for sure yeah um
some reviewers might know me uh if
they're mma fans i fought in the ufc
for quite a while i signed my first
contract with the parent company zuffa
llc
in 2009 and i was fighting in the wec
which is a small organization owned by
the same people
and then in 2011 they merged us then um
and you know i just i grew up obviously
with a very passionate
father who who if you heard him talk
these are the stories that i heard
growing up my entire life
so i always felt a duty because being
born here in the united states i never
once felt
uh or had to deal with an oppressive
government
or you know not being able to go out and
speak my mind in the street or do
anything like that
and because of the sacrifice advice is
made by people like my father
like my uncles like my grandfather and
friends of my father i i feel like i
have a duty to
to kind of continue the fight for those
people in cuba that
don't have a voice so well you said you
didn't have to live under an oppressive
government but that could be changing
especially as what's happening uh lately
we got ian shellin
what's up everybody ian crossland over
here thanks for coming guys
no problem thank you for inviting us
yeah and i am
so excited to have both of these guys
i'm really excited to have ricardo
because he
bought in the mma i'm so excited for his
dad because i used to love working with
older people and hearing their stories
and i'm excited you guys will get to do
that
get ready for a lot of stories there are
a lot of stories i'll just say right now
we need to we need to understand um how
cuba got to that point i think you can
help
shine a light on that so we'll jump into
that before we do head over to
timcast.com
become a member and you'll get access to
exclusive members only segments from
this show
you will get an ad free experience we
are working out the bugs so bear with us
we just launched the new site and we got
a lot of bugs don't we because we
we we we're growing as fast as we
possibly can i mean this is only six
months now we've had the site up
and we've already gotten this new
iteration we're gonna have a members
only segment uh coming up from this show
and you're also helping to support our
journalists of which we're gonna have i
think like six or seven
uh i think we have six or seven writers
now we're gonna be adding more and more
people to do more real journalism
do some on the ground field reporting
we've talked to some local reporters
and uh we're gonna start ramping things
up with your help as members so don't
forget
like this video right now subscribe to
this channel
and i'll tell you this um this is gonna
be a bit more conversational
normally we go through new segments but
we have to have a conversation about
what's happening in this country and
what's hap
what happened in cuba how they got to
that point and we've got some real
experience we can break that down for so
share
this with your friends anybody who might
be interested
interested in hearing the story from
actual witness and activists who are
fighting against
communism now i want to do this the
first thing i want to do is just
highlight the story to give us some
contemporary context this is from fox
news
washington dc removes cuba libre street
painting
from in front in front of the cuban
embassy embassy located in the same
street
where mayor bowser ordered painting last
year of black lives matter
i gotta say i was actually shocked to
see this even though i know the biases
of the establishment
i know that they support black lives
matter i know the black lives matter
activists say they're marxists i was
still surprised to see
that they would be as brazen as to
remove
cuba libre from the street they painted
black lives matter they had no approval
they took the tax money they painted it
this just shows you the the degree to
which the establishment in the u.s
is in favor of the communist
dictatorship of cuba and it is very
scary to me
we also have this story nicole hannah
jones
said cuba most equal western country
in a podcast the funny thing is it's
also aoc
it's also other progressive democrats
saying that oh the real
problem is the embargo it's not
communism so i wanna i wanna i wanna
i need to understand right i can see
what's happening here in the u.s
i can see the changes that are happening
but i'm interested uh
you know so you you're both activists
jose you were actually
born into a free and democratic cuba how
old were you when the communists took
over
i was 18 years old now when the
communists when this revolution
took over it was never intended
to have a socialist revolution
taking power and remaining in power for
six to
more than 62 years so i was
18 years old i had just graduated from
the marriage brothers
with a bachelor with a degree on
bachelor arts and i was planning to
attend havana university to study united
journalism and law and uh so you know
but basically what took cover was a big
lie
so so how big lie fidel when you you
were 18 when the revolution happened but
that wasn't a community no no when the
revolution
when batista fall down escaped cuba
and fidel took all the merits
of the revolution that had been also
launched by other organizations
by other leaders and other movements but
in 1959
fidel was able to control
all the power of himself and being
a great speaker and a huge flyer
he gained total support in cuba
that is the truth in 1959
but right after that his big lie began
to dismantle
and the truth came out and then
those same people that were with him
fighting batista that worked with him in
sierra maetra
like mayor yuber matos ten months after
he took power told fidel
i cannot continue in the way the
revolution is going i don't want to be
an obstacle to you i want to become
a teacher again before i went to the
sierra maetra
i want to be a teacher again and
good luck with the revolution that's
when
the big lie really became an oppressive
totalitarian idea of eliminating anybody
who dissent with you and that's when
fidel castro sent to come away where
huber matos was in charge of the
military
camilo siemphue was the chief of the
army
and with orders of apprehending him
and taking him to havana accusing him on
national radio fidel when he sent
camille over there
that huber matos was a traitor
and when camilo sinfoive got to come
away and saw
uber matos peaceful in his home with his
family and his kids
he had not rebelled against the
revolution
decided to tell uber stay here i got to
go back and talk to fidel
and then more lies began to continue
then they shut down camilo
because camilo did not follow castro's
order
orders of happiness apprehending uber
matters
and then they killed camilo's infuegos
and people started i started to blame
hubermattos on the fidel
direction now the responsible for
killing uber mottos
was over two how did it get to that
point how did the revolution happen
the revolution happened was very simple
and was a tremendous excuse
for natural
fulgencious march 10 1952
who had been by the way i would say a
good president in 1940
from 1944. he was actually an elected
president in cuba
before he threw his coup d'etat and came
into power so
that's like a little fact that maybe a
lot of people don't don't know
so with an excuse you know of
of uh uh
saving the country from fraud in the
upcoming elections batista
a few months before prio
ended was going to end his presidency a
new election were coming in
he decided to to start a
a revolution based on that on the
good data on the coupe data and from
that was the excuse and this is why
it is sad to to say that maybe batita
was not as bad
as people blame him to be during those
seven years
but the truth of the matter is that we
saw batita and the good excuse to fidel
to use the coup d'etat
as an issue for his revolution
nothing will happen in cuba because
fidel did not have
fidel had tried to be in the political
atmosphere
in to be part of a political party to be
elected in elections for small positions
and he never won anything but when
batista
gave the coup d'etat and in in in
the 26th of july of 1953 that was in
1952 the coup d'etat
in 26 uh july of 1953
he attacks the mancala barracks he
brings there a lot of
young cubans who were very ideal
idealists
and many of them died there but he
gained a name
and from that day he was born the 26th
of july revolutionary movement
so the the the batista yeah he he was
claiming there was fraud in the election
but claimed that he interrupted the
elections that were upcoming because
they were going to be fraudulent
and with that excuse he gave the coup
d'etat
of course nobody believed him
the thing the interesting thing if
people want to
think about this is that batita was in
power he was a dictator
but he didn't mess with the media
he didn't mess with the business he
didn't mess with enterprises
he just wanted to make some money and
be again a figure in cuba
but you know that that that basically
did not affect it at all the development
of cuba from 1953
or 1952 to 1959
chihuahua continued to grow cuba
continued to develop businesses
cuba continued to raise the standard of
living of the cuban people
the problem with the socialism and with
the revolution
the totalitarian revolution is not only
that they seek power
is that they destroy everything
and it's very clear and i am not here to
defend but i'm telling you what ita was
sadly enough the good excuse that fidel
had
to do all these things that he did
there's there's a lot of similarities
there to what we're seeing
in the u.s now donald trump well i mean
he's not he's not the fascist dictator
that bautista may have been but donald
trump has that hatred
the excuse the excuse they use society
feels it yeah to claim that they need
power they need new laws
they need to shut down their political
opposition quell dissent go after the
extremists
arrest them expand uh federal resources
and power and law i mean
you look at what they've been saying
about the far right about militia groups
and the threat of white supremacy
and uh of course it's not identical
there's a few things that i that i that
that's that feel
similar you have this guy trump they
call him a dictator they call him a
fascist
but he didn't aside from insulting the
media
he didn't shut down the press he may
have banned them from some of his his
events
he didn't call in the military to go and
crush protests or anything like that
certainly has his issues but because of
of what the media said about him because
of the view people had about him
the democrats now you know getting
elected are using that as an excuse
for basically everything among other
things to be completely honest
so my my fear is obviously we have we
have a lot of different things that are
happening in the u.s
outside of just the you know politics we
have covered with the pandemic you know
lockdowns and things like that are
coming
but i i you know i i wonder
with what we're seeing with the black
lives matter supporting com
the revolution they call it the
communist dictatorship in cuba they call
it the revolution
these are people who are gaining power
and prominence and i'm wondering what
your thoughts are on
you know their activism what they've
been doing and what that might mean for
us in the us
well for me black lives matter
is one of the worst
enemies because they are from within
that this country is facing and they
have
uh means
and they have the support of the media
and uh
because people are afraid to speak out
against them because they are most some
of them are
black but others are not black but for
for some reason they have obtained the
ability
to destroy this country to burn
you know to to finish things
to destroy cities to destroy property
that does not belong to them
and come out as a progressive people
and i don't that's ridiculous it's
it's it sounds like
authoritarian revolutionaries they've
got establishment power they control
institutions and they're
it sounds like they're gaining control
team when i see these people
that have no power doing the things they
do
how much destruction and death they have
caused
people don't realize in this country
that if they
ever get real power a lot of people are
going to be dead
but they do have they are gaining real
power that no no no but i mean
when they reach the government when when
they take over
this country nobody's going to be safe
only those
who with them will continue to oppress
the rest
i think it might be worse than you
realize mark milley the joint mark
millie the joint chiefs of staff
for the u.s is espousing their ideology
saying he's trying to learn about white
rage speaking in support of black lives
matter and condemning
conservatives and republicans as the
same as the nazis
that's that's the joint chiefs of staff
this is the highest level of
you know in the highest levels of our
government joe biden
is has you know removed bans on critical
race theory
components critical race applied
principles in
government trainings and contracting
maybe you know five years ago
you know i was probably saying the same
thing as you if these people ever gain
power and under government were in
serious trouble
they're there they're in the movie
studios they're in colleges
they're in every level of government and
you take a look at what the federal
government is now doing with the capital
police
the capital police they're just supposed
to be for the capital they're now
expanding nationwide
to operate as an intelligence agency so
i i can't uh
i wasn't alive uh in in pre-communist
cuba
but you know i just i wonder based on
the things you've been saying already
even before the show and what i've read
it seems like the u.s is headed down
that path and
you know you mentioned that you uh or it
was mentioned
i think you you were going to mention
this that you were part of the
anti-castro underground movement
opposing communism and um as noble as
that that sounds
it doesn't seem like it worked right
we're we're still to this day fighting
against
the remnants of that communist
revolution yes
it did not work because
sadly i have to admit the united states
did not help us the proper way
at the proper time because
we were alone we didn't have resources
we didn't have nothing to fight it's
more or less like today
that you can see all these cuban
protesting there they don't they don't
even
they they don't even have a gun and
they're not
using guns and and then you see the
the enemy that is being like into this
neighborhood
in 20 boss brought
security forces dressed in civilian
cloth
clothing all of them with with sticks
and clubs and hitting people you don't
even know
they are the state security so it is a
is a
it's a situation where always our
underground for different reasons
never got the right support from the
very beginning in the united states
should have helped us humans not not
intervene no
no no we had enough combatants inside
cuba
well there was the fear of uh the
soviets you know if we intervened so the
soviet union would have
you know threatened us or pushed back
maybe even could have ignited nuclear
war
i wasn't alive back then so you know i
can't speak as to the sentiment from
the people or in the press or anything
like that well i i think that there were
plenty opportunities to help cubans
in different ways uh uh that's what the
whole cuban missile crisis was about too
i mean yes yeah in uh the soviets were
putting missiles in cuba right yeah
and pointed at pointing them at the
united states so that's why uh
in the in the schools you know in those
time i think it was in the 50s
right no or the 60s yeah in uh
uh it was in 1962
the uh the october crisis
and uh and uh basically
it was known that that that the soviet
union had
established uh missiles in cuba and it
was discovered
and then uh kennedy and khrushchev work
work out a treatment a treat
and then as part of that trait where the
united states was supposed to do this
and
the soviet union was supposed to do that
the sad thing is that the united states
i think committed
not to ever help cubans
to freedom themselves and that's where
the the
the the destiny of the cuban people was
still
until today you know that has to be
broken that needs to be broken
absolutely uh you know in thinking about
what you're saying about black lives
matter
an enemy from within i mean they're
becoming so prominent it's almost like
i don't know if you guys are familiar
with the graphic novel i am legend
so uh in this story it's basically i'll
give you the very rough summary because
there's probably a lot of nuance i'm
missing as you know it's been a really
really long time since i read it
uh he's a vampire hunter and he goes
around
you know driving stakes through the
hearts of vampires but the vampires keep
spreading they keep infecting more
people and eventually
everyone is a vampire but him and then
so
when they arrest him as you know he's
this monster it turns out
when the majority of the society are all
vampires they look to him and they say
you're the bad guy
the monster who lurks while we sleep
killing our loved ones
so from our perspective you know he's
hunting vampires they're bad
but once everyone's a vampire he's bad
so what i mean by that is
the way it feels in the united states is
that sure we may be freedom loving
individuals who talk about free speech
and
the rights of uh you know freedom of
association movement the right to keep
and bear arms
but it looks like if if black lives
matter their their
bill de blasio new york play he paints
black lives matter
without without uh legal justification
without proper tax appropriation uh
funding funding and then he puts police
on top of that painting in the street in
front of trump tower
and they arrest people who dare defy him
we're already at that point
where the communists the marxists the
socialists
they're in the institutions they control
the major cities
they control the police departments so
we you know we can refer to them as bad
people
but they're they're in control they may
not represent most people but
it's definitely spreading around i i see
it too like on social media just
from these last few weeks where i've
been sharing all the stuff about cuba
you know all of these uh these socialist
uh sympathizing people are coming out of
the woodwork to like combat me on my
posts and
you know try and say that cuba is is
such a great country the us shouldn't
talk we're
we're uh we're worse than cuba i'm like
listen it's getting to a ridiculous
point where they even
try to compare a country like the u.s to
cuba and i always come back with them
like go
go do me one thing right go outside go
outside your house and go badmouth the
president to your neighbors or to
whoever will listen to you and if the
police don't show up and arrest you or
beat you
you're in no position to compare the
united states to a country like cuba
so i think i don't know where this
fascination came from it might come from
kind of mainstream media it might come
from like celebrities who kind of push
these ideologies on these younger kids
uh but it's it's a scary place to be
right now and
it's it's even more scary to think about
what the future would be like for my
kids growing up in this country well
we're certainly not uh
as bad as cuba is yet and that's why
there's there's hope that you know maybe
our underground movement or you know
resistance might actually
stop the encroachment of this this
communist authoritarian ideology for now
we're we're able to have these
conversations but you take a look at
what's happened to people's careers
when they dig up you know your history
from 20 years ago they get you fired
because of things your parents said
we're certainly not at that point where
they're going to come to your house and
they're going to beat and arrest you
however
we are at that point where we have seen
rioters go to the homes of people
say in portland they threatened to burn
down a man's home because he had an
american flag
many people have started saying that
flying the american flag is
is a sort of underhanded way of showing
that you support donald trump or that
you support this country the united
states
and i'm kind of like well waving the
flag shows you're waving the flag for
this country
but in certain cities it can be it can
be bad news for you
if one of these riots breaks out if
black lives matter has sufficient
numbers or antifa and you're you're
flying that flag
they will beat and attack you in fact in
boston several years ago
there was an uh a rally against nazis
of course there were no nazis showing up
in boston it was just
hysteria but you had 40 000 people
protesting who they thought were nazis
when it was actually some
indian guy who's you know like running
for office
but there was an older woman who i
believe was in her late 50s early 60s
and she was holding an american flag
and some far left individual grabbed the
flag and
pulled it from her dragging her out
pulling her to the ground and then
dragging her
as they tried to take her her flag from
her
so we're certainly at the point where
they have institutional authority and
that you were right you said if these
people ever get true power
what do you think these people are going
to do if they're given a badge
that that is that is truly worrying to
me that we're you know we're
we're we're seeing that starting to
happen in the united states not that
they're getting badges of course
but they're trying to they want these
these woke police we saw i don't know if
you saw what happened at evergreen
college
where these leftist extremists took
baseball bats and were walking around
campus attacking people
or what happened at the quote-unquote
autonomous zone the no-go zone in
seattle
where several of the security forces for
the seattle autonomous zone
opened fire on an suv with with some
teenagers in it
severely injuring and killing one if
these people are successful in
abolishing the police
in the way they want and creating or i
should say not even abolishing the
police but creating their social justice
as they call it police forces
then you will have people show up at
your house and say you've bad-mouthed
the movement
and they'll start beating you um jose
what was um the gun rights
like in cuba in the 40s and the 50s
you could have your guns and uh you
could go
you know and uh
target practice don't
there was no problem and cuba was
very peaceful we we
for for guns to be
something so bad uh
some illness have to be
in the minds of so many people that they
use them wrong
probably but the problems are not the
guns are the people and if you
and if you have people that hate uh
whether it's a gun or not you can go and
smash somebody's head or destroy
somebody's property
which is the same thing and you can do
it with a gun or or with
no gun did bautista take the guns no
castro no no yes what year yeah in 1959
i tell you i tell you what there was a
speech a famous
speech of ideal the problem is this
fidel takes over but really there are
other organizations and movements
that also had guerrilla forces fighting
batista
different organizations okay
revolutionary organizations and
students organizations like the
directorial revolutionary to the until
that you know they they had
fighting fronts okay and then in order
for fidel to control the movement
he needed to disarm everybody else
and then he asked a beautiful question
guns for what
for what and then he demanded that
all politic all organizations that had
fought but
batita give their their guns
it seems like it was a mistake and they
all did they all do it peacefully
yes yes because fidel had
at that time a tremendous power on the
people
not because people wanted to have a
socialistic dream that he had
made them think of fidel never spoke
about socialism or spoke good about
communism
he always denied that
but he was a charismatic leader
that somehow made people think at the
end
well if you say you are communist if you
say you are socialist
put me in the list and that is the
mentality
that really made it very difficult for
us
to fight in the 1961 1962
1963 fidel
because still there were people
believing that he was like like a god
but that had nothing to do with whether
they wanted socialism or not because
not until 1961 fidel declared the
revolution
socialist that was the headline
using the invasion of iran where then he
stopped lying in 1961 this
the 17th of april of 1961 the newspaper
cuban revolution
had a headline with six words
we will defend our democratic
and socialist revolution until that and
and
he used the invasion of iran as an
excuse
to then declare socialist cuba
you mentioned that he was a you know
very charismatic and he had this
hold on the people i wonder if uh you
know i wonder what your thoughts are on
trump
well look i am not a hypocrite
i like trump
i like the the fact that a person speaks
out
what has what he has in his mind
i credit that maybe because i know
another leader fidel castro
who did the contrary he lied he lied
and he lied again and he lied again
until he found the way to say his truth
when the invasion came in and used that
as an excuse to declare the socialist
state let me clarify something about
trump okay
i am a cuban citizen still i didn't come
to this country to be an american
citizen
i came to this country to continue being
a freedom fighter
and to do that i needed to remain a
cuban
because i was committed for life if i
become an american citizen then i have
other things
no no i wanted to remind myself no
matter how good or bad i was
and i started working in in
factories in production lines in a print
shop because i love papers and printing
and propaganda
i never and i had success
i made a lot of money but it never was
my intention
i didn't come here to make money didn't
come here to look for food to
buy me shoes i came here because at a
time
all the avenues in hue were close to me
close
close i was emotionally destroyed after
a fall
after after an event that didn't go the
way it should have gone
and i don't see how it would have been
gone good anyway because it was
crazy what we did and that destroyed me
and my organization said bonifacio i
think
if you want we have the embassy for you
and you can continue working there and
that's what i did
but let me finish about trump something
i like that man i have never voted for
anybody
and i am not here to say vote for trump
in a second
whatever i don't i don't care about that
but americans have to understand that in
this country
anybody should have the right to speak
out what they think
nobody to have the right to lie okay
and not to be confronted the media says
that donald trump lies all the time
though
no why what is it what is his lie i mean
tell me a couple of those lines
i i don't know if he lies or not but
he's saying something openly
and you can prove he's a lie then you
know he's a liar
but but the problem is that how many
people are here
telling us lies and nobody says anything
about it
i would just say if the media
institutions are supporting
you know black lives matter the
individuals who are praising castro
and right now praising the communist
regime and um
look i i i fact check news stories every
single day
they use deceptive framing techniques
and manipulation
to present falsehoods as it were
and then when i look at the things
they've said about donald trump you know
what
he lies but he lies about really dumb
things like how many women he's been
with or like
you know how he's the best and everyone
knows it it's like really
how much money he has yeah yeah yeah but
but there's something amazing in that
even the intercept which is very
anti-trump progressive
called him simultaneously the most like
deceit decep
deceptive and honest president we've
ever had there's one very famous moment
where he's you know he's about to get on
the helicopter and they asked him what
was happening
you know with saudi arabia and stuff and
he goes oh it's fantastic we're doing
this excellent weapons deal we're gonna
make millions of dollars
and everyone and all the anti-war left
activists their jaws hit the floor like
trump just came out and said it there
was another point
where trump was trying to withdraw
troops from syria and he goes they tell
me that we can't take out our trump uh
all of our troops from syria so we're
leaving 200 you know for the oil because
we're gonna protect the oil
and then everyone's just like he's just
admitting what the us
does with their foreign policy so i
think one of the challenges is that
there's always a risk there's a
charismatic leader who's going to come
in who's going to entrance people and
lie to them
but i have been i've been wading through
the muck in the mire for years and i can
just see
non-stop lies from the media
so it's different it's not the same you
say fidel castro was his charismatic
leader he had everybody
i mean where was the press were they
challenging him were they were they
calling him a liar
what press he destroyed the press what
year
in uh by 1960 you could not really
you know for example i i didn't tell you
in uh in in 1959
when the revolution took over i i began
to
think about a figure of the revolution
that was very important during the
organization of the 26th of july
movement that nobody
nobody spoke about him anymore
and and and we had a radio program
where we started to talk about this uh
cuban figure
and three or four weeks after we were on
the air
fidel asked the director of the credit
registration that
had given us the time to put off to put
us off the earth and that was 1960.
they had already confiscated that radio
station
they were already putting colettias
where a newspaper writes a small column
and then the government will put at the
end of that column
a qualitative the ending phrase saying
this is a lie
and all that and then immediately after
that there was no more
no more dead cuba doesn't know katrina's
cuba
didn't know right after he took over
what was freedom of the press
all media was controlled and it's
controlled by the government there is no
opinion nothing else no you cannot
create even good or bad public opinion
the government is the one that creates
the opinion they want
what are we seeing now with uh joe biden
the bun administration
that they they're going to that they're
currently flagging
misinformation for facebook that they
they they are
are pushing a list of the greatest
misinformation individuals on the
internet
that they're working with the dnc the
democrats and phone carriers to
to censor private text messages
so when i see a bombastic man of donald
trump
but one who mostly just insulted the
press
compared to what the current
administration is doing in in actually
trying to
circumvent the constitution to take away
the rights of people just to shut down
their free speech
and their allies very much progressive
leftists in
big tech it sounds like we're heading
towards a similar direction to what
happened
in in cuba that's why a lot more people
need to look at
you know cuba is only 90 miles away from
from our shores
and it's the perfect blueprint of what
happens when you put in place a
communist dictatorship or communism and
socialism
everything's ruined everything's falling
apart nothing has moved on that island
since 1959 that's why
people drive around and all these old
cars that they literally have to just
keep
inventing things to keep the cars
running you know buildings are falling
apart
um i believe it was last year there are
three little girls playing in
in uh in the street they they were
killed just from falling rubble of a
building
you know everybody's houses are falling
apart but they're building hotels for
the tourists to come and stay at which
cuban citizens are not allowed to use
i was going to say the the the the
progressives in this country say that's
the fault of the u.s and their embargo
no but they're building hotels in my
opinion whether
whether the embargo stays or is lifted
the cuban people are going to be in the
same spot because for the regime it's
all about control they control
everything that comes in they control
everything that goes out
uh as it is right with the scraps that
they have they can barely afford those
scraps
uh the the average cuban makes about 20
30
u.s dollars a month and they're paid
they're not even paid in dollars they're
paid in pesos in cuban pesos but
at the stores where you go and you want
to buy something you have to buy it in
dollars
wow so how does that make sense at all
you know and it's
man it's just everything's like upside
down there's broken yes completely
so you you ended up in the underground
movement against castro
yes during during the when he was with
gaining power
during the initial confrontation where
people realize
at the beginning i thought that they
read for example i went to see ramayana
as a volunteer
volunteering teacher before i when i
graduated
just for contact was the mountain range
in cuba where
uh fidel's army was was hiding out
during the revolution
so that's where all of his troops were
and so my dad went up there as a
volunteer okay
castro make a a call to
secondary graduates people have just
graduated from secondary
to go to teach and read the farmers
and then i volunteer and
the sad thing is that i volunteered in
1959
and they called me 1960 and
we went to havana university they they
got us together
there were about you know a thousand
applicants they gave us
like a test uh remember one question
when was the first battle
of the guerrilla in sierra
i remember december 5th alegria del piu
so they they gave us a test probably to
make sure how much we knew about the
revolution
and they selected 500 of those kids
that volunteered to be to become
teachers of farmers
so in 1959 i wanted to do that
actually i would love i would have loved
to to be a teacher not only a journalist
or
or a lawyer i i like actually in channel
44
that i ran for 10 years
i developed a cold show but a cheetah
little path
a kid's show and we weren't we won an
enemy with it oh channel 44 in chicago
yeah oh yeah yeah i always joke that my
dad was the cuban mr rogers oh wow
i used to watch him he was he was on the
show i did a show
pets the best friends of kids and this
guy had a few pets
yeah so he he came in the show he came
to our to our taekwondo school too
yeah first time i displayed my martial
arts on tv
when i when i was little we didn't have
cable and the only only way to watch
dragon ball z was in spanish on channel
44.
yeah oh wow that's crazy well i can't
tell you a lot of it
about channel 44 because when i went to
channel 44 for the first time was not to
run channel 44
but i bought an hour once a day
and i run on a spanish soap opera and i
did all my logs and my
slides and my pro my production sitting
on the cafeteria
at that time channel 44 was white sox
bulls
and bob losing wrestling those shows
well let's go back to what you were
saying about okay yeah yeah so so
uh you violent you volunteer yeah i
volunteer because
but the sad thing is that i volunteered
myself in 1959
and they called me 1960
in in may to go to sierra maetra
i had already been i had already
considered that the revolution betray
you were matus
but still i wasn't ready to fight the
revolution
i didn't i didn't know how to do it
i felt persecuted they wrote an article
no they they wrote an article in the
newspaper saying
that at the marist brothers the school
where i story
there were there was a fight between two
kids
one that was a revolutionary kid and one
that was not a revolutionary kid
and that the the revolutionary kid got
the bad energy
of it and then they what that was the
first attempt to destroy in cuba
private education i wrote an article
no i asked the director of the school to
allow me to go
class by class to investigate where that
incident had occurred
in third grade i found two kids
that because one wanted to erase the
blackboard and the other didn't want
after after school
helping the teacher they got into a
little match
and nothing nothing happened there so i
wrote an article
called falsa facil
false easy
or very easy to make a
a statement that is not true completely
false
did the the the the accusation
of jesus uh what the world
was the non-revolutionary kid that was
in the fight no no no no jesus
is the the revolutionary leader that
made the accusation that in that
school that incidentally happened and
that was at the miss
of when the government wanted to destroy
private education i wrote on a a
i did a little research wrote an article
and said that this wasn't true
and i went to the newspaper in all
havana that had published that that
article okay and i asked
for them to publish the article and they
threw me
down down in all havana the buildings
have very long stairs
and and the guy took me and pushed me
down that i almost got killed
wow and still i thought that that there
was a mistake okay
that this guy made a mistake not that
the revolution was bad
so this is why i went to sierra madre
i thought that maybe still there was a
hope
that the revolution wouldn't end up the
way i was beginning to see
and since and then and then my mother
and my mother said look
go and talk to your father before you go
to sierra maestra
because my father who was a very civic
and patriotic person
who had been in jail during batista his
brother
spent prison a time in prison during
batista too
his brother ended up being a captain of
the revolutionary police of cuba
serving a sentence of 20 years on the
end of being 23 years
so so i went to sierra i went to talk to
my father because my mother said look
you
you are gonna go you haven't asked
permissions for for your father
and my father said nino that he called
me boy we were i was the smaller of the
three
of the three brothers although we were
about only one year and a half and said
and he said nino uh why why do you want
to go as a volunteer teacher i said that
uh you know i love teaching uh this is a
commitment i made
you know a year ago and they called me
and i told him don't worry about it
because you know how much i love
the teaching and the doctoring of
assembly
i have read jose marti a lot sometimes i
wrote i wrote things
that look like society and and i wasn't
coping whose mrt i
i was so much enticed by
by the teachings of our patriarchy
that i told him nobody's going to be
able to get me out of that route
and i was right i didn't know
in may 19 1960 being a crmiser
may 19 was the day in
18 uh 1985
that mati died fighting for cuba's
independence
and in in the sierra madre a group of my
companions we decided to organize a
tribute to jose marti's
anniversary and i spoke there
and what i said about jose marti
and since my speech did not refer to
nothing of the revolution or nothing
like that
just about the spirit of the doctrine of
society
the chief of the the guy that was in
charge of the campaign
called me on siren said and no more
talking now
you guys go and finish we were building
a barrack because we had just
got in there we were building a barrack
for us to hang our
sleeping bags or whatever and then he
said
you guys are not going to eat until you
finish
building the barrack and i and i told
this guy and i was expelled in
in the point i told this guy listen wait
wait wait
how do you call me volunteer teacher
do you know what volunteer teacher means
i am here as a volunteer
and i are not going to build any finish
any
barracks if you have food you have to
give it to us now
and that's it that was night and then
they expelled me
i i left sierra maestra walking
i go to mina del frio
mina del frio was right there next to
pico turquino the biggest
mountain of cuba you could see from
there
it was a valley among the mountains like
a flat terrain
and that was a a a
a school for the military
farmers and things that and they had a
lot of answer an ammunition
there was very major okay and that mayor
i went to him and said this is what
happened to me at the magdalena la
magdalena was the campament
where where i there were three campaigns
for the 500
volunteers and that was one and his name
was aldo santa maria the mayoral santa
maria
i was looking for this revolution to
again in my case
fix a mistake and then i looked for aldo
santa maria thomas in the capitania i
went over there there were about 10
captains in a wooden
beak like like a little office uh how do
you carry a cabin or whatever
and and then i said uh i said commandant
they say
what do you want i said well i need you
to investigate something
i came here as a volunteer teacher from
la magdalena
i just was expelled why
no i don't want you to go in bacteria we
were just talking about society
and then this guy said look
have you eaten no oh he said okay he
took me to the front of the cabin
you see over there there is food over
there in a houston
you go there sleep the night there and i
am going to investigate what happened
come here tomorrow at six o'clock in the
morning this is in the middle
of la mina del frio a huge
secret military base where they have a
lot of things important things going on
in there
so i go there next morning i go to see
uh aldo santa maria aldo santa maria was
the brother of
abel santa maria who was the
one of the biggest and first martyrs of
the cuban revolution
and and uh and him he had died
and his brother now was a major
commander of the revolution so
i was impressed having met aldo santa
maria
and then he says okay come back i went
back and when i
go back i entered the coming there were
this a lot of captains there and he says
okay
uh i did not send anybody to investigate
uh i have a request for you
stay here with me stay here with me
and i it really he really took me off
because
i have been a boy scout i love mountains
you know i i never liked guns but you
know the discipline i mean the
the challenge i i felt like
enticed maybe to say yes but i said
mayor santa maria i did not come here to
become a soldier
if you cannot address my problem
then i must leave i
i don't want to be here and then he said
fine i said well how am going to live
when we came in they brought us
to go out they were little a lot of
pulse
posts where you need to be identified to
get out
from there you are in in a military
territory
and he said don't worry about it he
wrote in a piece of paper to let me go
through
everything and he gave it to me and said
thank you very much
and i hit the door and when i was
leaving
aldo santa maria said holden
boy what is your name
i said jose francisco llamas and then
and then he challenged me for the rest
of my life
he said jose you are going to be
or very good or very bad
but he let me go and these are
when you say you know the beginning of
this revolution
uh me and i am putting myself only as an
example
of many people that love this revolution
that tried to serve the revolution
that tried to wait for the 18 months for
having general
elections and that waiting for the
constitution to be in place in 1940
constitution which were the two main
promises
of fidel castro to establish the 1940
constitution to call for elections
when we saw none of that happening and
when me
as a person me realized that i've been
persecuted
i found myself that the only way that i
could get out of that situation
was fighting this revolution that i
thought at a time that might have been a
good thing
and that's and that is the process but
by the time that we decided to do that
fidel had imprisoned most of the big
leaders of the good revolution
that did not become a part of the
communist takeover
and we were you know we had no resources
and we had no help and there were no
press
and we did crazy things but we we
this is what a lot of the young people
here in the u.s and many other places
don't realize
that if they actually get their
evolution they are actually the biggest
threat
to those who want to seize power the the
the layabouts in this country the
regular people who
don't do anything well they're no threat
to the authoritarians they don't do
anything
revolutionaries they're a big threat to
revolutionaries
so that's why i'm not surprised to hear
that you know fidel imprisoned the other
leaders in the revolution
immediately and it was not only in
prison
send them to deferring a squad
saying like you know the only reason why
he could not do that to
her matos because uber motto was
i would say in the five major leaders of
the revolution in the sierra matra
ubermatto were one of them the biggest
shipment of guns that got to sierra
uber matos delivered from from costa
rica he landed there were a small
plane and he brought the best armament
that the gorilla had seen
and we were mad of being a teacher he
was a teacher to his soldiers
and and his and his troops were
really committed to ideals
not to following people they they had
their
he he has spread among his followers in
his troop
the the thoughts of of democracy
and fighting for freedom and so he had a
very cohesive
his army his his his pose
mato had a real good p people that were
were convinced of his ideals
and fidel was afraid that that had
permeated
among other drugs of the revolution and
and
was afraid to imprison to kill uber
matus
but he tried to destroy him and he spent
20 years in prison
were there were there
counter-revolutionary forces people
opposing
obviously there were battles no they
were we we never no they call us contra
revolutionaries
these revolutionaries there opposite
revolution
we were called counter revolutionaries
but we were the revolutionaries
with the revolution now the problem is
when you
opposing revolution then you are a
gusano
yeah and you are a counter-revolutionary
i haven't changed
you know ideas do not change
okay sometimes you are in favor you can
do it in favor sometimes you gotta do it
against
but that doesn't mean you are a [ __ ] or
nothing you are pro your own idea if you
have ideas the problem in this country
is
that i don't think people have the right
ideals
how long were you in in this you know
underground movement against castro how
long were you actively trying to oppose
castro
1960 to not to the end of 1962
and uh i i mean living wherever i could
and sleeping wherever i could and and i
didn't even know that
that i was missing anything it never
occurred to me
okay i live i don't know even how but i
live
and i was fully embraced
by by what we were doing as with my my
with my friends
like lucia sanchez that might be
listening to this podcast right now in
chicago
when she was young as i as i was young i
was a little bit older than she was
and uh i was so much
in love with with our group and
we became family then
then she married one of our companions
that went to jail
the brother of a companion of ours that
when i was the national head of the
student sector
of the third november revolutionary
movie and i seek refuge at the brazilian
embassy
i gave him the folder that i had kept
with all our papers
that was in at the end of july 1962 his
name was luis sanchez carpentier
so and he was caught on the 30th of
august
and by the uh on on september 21st
he was already executed wow
okay and and what was what was the
regime's excuse
oh because this this is my
my theory the regime
had different ways of destroying the
opposition
the number one was to infiltrate
our groups our group
the 30th november revolutionary movement
from pais
since was a group that came from the
revolution itself
it was very easy that anybody being a
an official of the revolutionary
government
would come to us because we were
identified
truly with the real revolution and with
the real purposes of the revolution
so if a g2 guy comes to us
and he declares that you know he wants
to be with us
you know we were like like a perfect
target
for people that were revolutionary to
join us g2 were like the military police
of castro's revolution
okay and the second thing that they did
and this this is what happened to my
friend
they they you they know
the the security knows you have a plan
and they had a plan on november 30th
of 1962 there will be a general
insurrection of cuba and at that time
all those military people a lot of
people still were in power
were supposed to join us join my
my my group and the other groups to
rebel
against the revolution but that plan
was really built
by the state security police
okay they really control the
organization
of that thing because there is no other
way of explaining
that if there are let's say
10 000 people organized to do something
on a particular date a particular night
that that morning everybody gets into
prison
how in the world could that happen
unless that or
that that of that uprising
had been planned by the by the regime
yeah the trap
the truck so is th is this when you you
went to the berlin
brazilian embassy and this is no no no
he was already in the brazilian embassy
when
his group was infiltrated no no my group
was infiltrated before by many other
people
in many other ways that that movement
when they're all around yeah that moving
was something that
they created i don't know from from
where
because in july 28
okay i participated in an action
to disarm okay some people
okay because we didn't have arms
and somebody in my organization told me
i'm gonna be leaving the embassy
i gotta go to the united states when i
come back i'm gonna
organize something to come back i need
you to have arms
and he gave me two ways of getting the
arms
go to go to oriental province
where in siena we had
a front and the people that that were in
the guerrilla force
at that place were destroyed and
assassinated
but it looks like there were some arms
that were hiding
somewhere in oriente province okay
in a town called campechuela so
this guy that at the time was sort of my
boss
said you go to campechuela
and find those arms and i went to
campechuela with a friend of mine
there there is another episode of
something ridiculous that happened to us
the biggest
scare that i had in that trip but anyway
i go to campechuela and there are
the ladies that i'm supposed to see in
this town
she doesn't know nothing about anything
or she didn't trust me
so i i i asked knowing that i might not
find the arms i asked my
my boss or my my leader what do i do
if i don't find the i said well take it
away from the army
okay and we develop a crazy idea a crazy
plan
of young people going to take the arms
with no you know we we had some hours
okay and that was a catastrophe
okay yeah so that happened at the end of
july
of 1962. in that cataract trophy
okay i shot
trying to defend a friend of mine and be
he was paralyzed
or without garcia i have been hiding in
his house
he was one of my closest friends in the
underground
the other the other there were three
participants
in that plan the other person that was
participating
both are dead already this is why i'm
telling this story i'm the only one
alive
the other one was shot in the leg by
crossfire
we tried to steal a car we needed to
steal a car
to use that car to go and do the
operation
and then move the little arms that we
got
into our other car so we didn't want to
burn
our only car all the transportation so
the when we went to to steal this car
that's when the whole situation came
about
because what happened to me
and what i did accidentally
i was emotionally destroyed that day i
escaped
mira miraculously because
where the incident happened near to
malecon a lot of press on us
a few shots and all of the showing
when i am trying to get my my friend out
of the car that was shot
i didn't know how seriously at the time
i heard boots of people running walking
were cha cha
cha cha like like a like a a group of
soldiers
okay and my friend said go bonnie go
and i started to walk away
and i heard saying bonnie you killed me
and i came back and at the end he said
bonnie go
and i went but i took a pistol
from the other friend of mine that was
shot on the left
and the picture that i had and he
thought going that way i came
i went into the same direction where the
where the soldiers were coming
with one hand in one pocket and one hand
in the other pocket
and the idiots let me go through them
and i
said call well we can't we can't hear
you
i said i'm sorry i said i said
call emergency there are people hurt in
that car over there
and they let me go through brian
well that situation
forced me physically and mentally
to leave the underground because
the only thing that i could have done at
that time is to allow them to get me i
had no more
spark to jump out of a car as i did once
to run out of my house when the g2 came
to get me
and and resulted on my parents being on
under arrest for two weeks because they
were waiting they didn't want my parents
to go out
to think that there was nothing wrong in
my house and they thinking that i will
come back i escaped on my occasion
in many different ways but i never
had emotionally been hurt
or emotionally felt that i needed to
to do something else that i didn't want
to continue
and that's where the next day
i called luis sanchez carpenter
at el prado paseo del prado whereas a
kid
i have been playing in the iron lions
that are in this paseo del prado
beautiful
you know walk through with trees and as
a kitten
my father used to take me there and in
one of those benches
with the folder of my organization in my
hand that i had collected
from from all the things that we had
done with the robot staff of the
organization
i gave it to luis sanchez carpenter okay
that was about july 29
or july 30. after that
the next day i met with the coordinator
of my organization a cuban architect
that liked me a lot and protected me a
lot and said
it's a bonnie i have secured
a an entrance to the brazilian embassy
in case i need it
but i think you need it do you think you
want to go to exile
and i said enrique
where else can i go i am detroit
and then i see i went there and there
was another story how i had to wait for
a minute
between two soldiers when i have been
persecuted and when i have participated
so many things
waiting for the guy to open the door in
the embassy
i tried to get a friend of mine that is
listening to
tony antilla who was a lieutenant of
cartoon railroad army
i have to once i got to the embassy i
got a permit to get him in
and when he got there and stood in front
of the same door
and press the button the soldier got him
and that done to let him get into the
embassy wow
so that was uh terrible
but so this is you basically leaving
you're going into exile
going into the embassy right there of
course they didn't give me my safe
conduct there were a hundred
humans there and the and the strategy of
the minister of public
of relations of of cuba who should have
given us our safe conduct
was not to give anybody a safe conduct
so the embassy could not bring any more
people there
but what happened because of the
fascination that was in there
and the problems that we faced there two
people got killed
inside the embassy and then the
government of brazil
one committed suicide wow
one was killed
and one committed suicide because
that trauma in the embassy the
government of brazil that was socialist
at the time
or friendly with the with the cuban
government there were not too many other
countries that had diplomatic relations
in 1962
with brazil they sent
a a military representation of brazil
a a military plane
and they told simply raul who was the
minister of
the stereo relation you either give us
the same the 100 safe conduct of these
political exiles
or we break poli relations wow
and they they gave us our safe conducts
and then
i was able to leave cuba you went to
brazil after seven no
they they gave us the opportunity to go
to the united states to
san juan so they flew us in this
military plane that we saw at the
beginning that was like a sabotage
two kilos because was an old artifact
from second world war
didn't have any eating situation it
looks to us when we got in the plane
that they were going to drop out
somewhere you know not in puerto rico
but we
we we reached puerto rico and uh
i spent two weeks in puerto rico i had a
brother in chicago
who sent me the money and then i flew
two weeks after that
from san juan to chicago and i have been
in chicago
since february of 1963. it's been a it's
been a long time
since 1962 but now we're seeing people
in cuba start to
protest down with dictatorship are you
getting that spark back do you fear
do you feel hopeful he never lost that
spark i mean
since he left i think there hasn't been
a day that's passed that he hasn't
thought about
uh you know the cause of bringing
freedom back to cuba and he
he every every single day that i can
remember every single chance that he's
had
he is uh dedicated his life here to that
fight for freedom in cuba whether it's
through his uh
cuban civic committee where they put on
um events throughout that
money yeah but i mean there's tons of
stuff that he's been doing
so to answer your question there was no
spark that needed to come back it was
the fire has always been burning since
the day he left
well there's more hope now if i if i
understand your question is well what is
my reaction well
is is a reaction of of
sadness that people
had no other chance of surviving
than living day by day and could not
really
free themselves because they in my case
okay i had no problem in being in the
underground
it was for me great
i didn't have anything didn't have no
security didn't have i wasn't afraid of
anything didn't even know
that i was in danger
but i never had a son
that would go to bed without milk
i i never had a mother
that was dying with no medical services
i was a young healthy cuban
doing whatever he needed he learned in a
school
as i said i i i had the pressure of
having had
a better education that might than the
economic situation of my parents could
afford
but we didn't have a car we live in a
middle
class neighborhood low lower middle
class
not bad in el cerro was okay
and i i had a good standard of living
but people today had not been able to do
what i did
because they had responsibility with
their families i didn't have
there are many young people that don't
have families but they needed to survive
on a day-to-day day-to-day day-to-day
they never took
for me was for for me was not a process
of not being able to eat or to find food
to fight i fought
and then i had no food and i didn't give
i don't want to say
okay never never felt hungry
i i on the contrary i always felt okay
and then my friends will come and one
will say one day
oh what two sides you were
because he saw holes on my on my shoes i
was sitting in a bathroom in a bench in
parque central waiting for alejandro
moreno
maya one of the guys that was with me
the day that i
jumped out of a car when they take they
were taking me to prison
and alejandro maya looked at my shoes
and said what size do you charge you you
wear
okay so next week i am in the parque
central de la vana waiting for him again
and he comes laughing with a box of
shoes no chooser
and you know i didn't i didn't even know
i didn't have but i didn't even care
about the truth that i have but today
and the revolution have been able to
control the cuban people
by scarcity by hunger
by starvation but there is a point a
breaking point
for people too i would like to talk i
don't want to forget write it there i
want to talk about the su
the q1 program in hanoi during the
vietnam war oh yeah
okay but now the people have
suffered so much that i think they are
in a catatonic
state they don't give
nothing about what happens now they are
willing to risk it now
they have nothing to lose now castro is
dead
and his brother raul yeah is he dead no
he's not alive
is he in control he wasn't he
destinated uh he said
is now the like acting president and
face of the regime in cuba no
is he willing to give it up no no no no
no
he's a bureaucrat he has power he did
nothing for the revolution he didn't
fight
batita he did nothing he just was you
know a good
he observed the theory of marxism
he lives uh in a huge mansion
with swimming pool do you think he's
gonna give up
that his his actual you know he he was
addressing
um i saw a video he's addressing people
about the protests and
his exact words were uh you know if they
want to face off
with the revolution they're gonna have
to walk over our dead bodies so
you know his answer is he yeah and he
gave an order for combat in the streets
we're going to go to the streets and
we're going to he said he he called on
the revolutionary citizens to fight back
yep it's amazing how they refer to
themselves as the revolution when
they've been the dictators for decades
generations dictators and traders they
are
traitors to the revolution and by the
way
when we use the world revolution really
we it was not a revolution social with
social or nothing
it was a movement to get rid of a
dictator
that we have for seven years and go back
to what we were not jumping with ideas
and plans and things that never happened
or that would never never achieve their
things like the stories of the chickens
in the farm feed they'll say oh we got
started with this farm we're going to
have so many chickens
and then and then and we're gonna have a
hundred million chickens here soon
and there were no chickens and nothing
appeared and nothing
happened do you understand yeah the the
command
the command economies don't work i mean
we saw it with uh with mao when he said
kill all the birds kill all the pests
and then they destroyed their their
their ability to farm
yeah all of a sudden the locusts came
and started sweeping across uh china
no no farmers in cuba now are starving
they are not allowed to sell what they
what they can produce they don't know
how to produce everything has to be
controlled by the government
everything has to go through them this
is why i say
please americans open your eyes
cuba doesn't need food
q1 doesn't need humanitarian aid
q1 needs to get rid of the dictatorship
that will absorb anything you send over
there
nobody in the streets is saying i want
food i want a vaccine against kobe
no they want freedom they know it's the
only thing
but what can america do well americans
should get involved in that
i think that the american government
should help us
at this time do you know what happened
in in 1961 with the basis of hirono
okay there were you know in miami
uh as as young cubans began to
go from havana to cuba to miami
in miami when they knew they were going
to prepare a force to fight
they already started to volunteer also
known as a bay of pigs
that's right oh yes right right right
okay they they started to volunteer and
they
wanted to to to go to cuba to live at a
cuba
but then kennedy changed the plans
and kennedy was told but listen
what do we do with the 1500 cubans
that want to go and then his advisor
said well
mr president they want to go to cuba
they want to go to fight
and then he said okay send them
but no air coverage
no support that was sending sending
the best of the cuban youth in exile
to die
this country has to
pay us back because after that
you know what had happened in 62 years
we humans expect the united states
to behave like the united states maybe
in the 50s i don't know i don't know
when to go back
okay but i do know that the united
states had a prestige and international
prestige
that we cubans were in love with the
american dream
that we were living in our own country
and that we relieved when
ours ended and we came here looking to
establish you know a new life i came
looking for something different to tell
you the truth
in miami this past election there was a
safe democrat district
in an urban center no one saw this
coming
the republican got elected the
continuing pushes
from the far left the the marxists the
black lives matter groups
is turning many of these you know in
like south texas for instance and in
florida
it's turning democrat areas into
republican areas and it's and
very likely because especially in miami
obviously the people who know the
horrors of socialism and communism
are seeing that within the united states
and pushing back against it so perhaps
that's that's that's a sign of hope for
us here that we won't let it happen
and i wonder if the if people in the
united states are willing to
do anything to help cuba you know here
the cubans are
you know pushing back against the
problems here but will it go the other
day think about the spanish-american war
in 1898 when the spanish empire
controlled cuba yeah and the americans
liberated cuba yeah and then let it let
it go
no it's not correct what happened it's
not correct you're the same monkeys
i mean maybe you read it in a book like
that
but cuba have fought for its uh
freedom since 1821 in 1851
there were different movements 1868
el grito de llara ten years
fighting the spaniards okay
the the cuban guajiros the mambissa
cubanos
then came the 1895 war
okay and after we had done
most of the fighting and put most of the
debt
uh the main blew up
so somehow i am not going to discuss
here yeah
some people say that that uh
that the united states blue domain
i don't believe it okay and i don't care
what happened now
it doesn't matter what what what
happened it doesn't matter
it was an excuse of the united states to
intervene
and then they intervened but you cannot
say
they won the war they no no we
cuba were already in the in the final
stretch jose marti had already died
a few months after he landed in orient
and to fight for what he had been
preaching for many
years he had been in prison who was 15
years old
by the spaniards okay so when you say
the americans want the war no
they intervene actually
they did a few things that were not
right like not allowing
some manbissa forces
to be respected for what they they
they were and to be giving more
authority
but they but the americans or you know
the united states
end up allowing
cuba to be a
republic and they
created with the help of cubans
a constitution which in 1940
we changed and became really a human
constitution
but they gave us the framework okay
to establish a democratic republic
but we cannot give them the credit for
winning the war
i what i get concerned of is that what
before when it was
independent cuba that it was what how
did batista come to power
it feels like it was usurped it was
ridiculous
but ita came to power without
killing anybody with without fighting
one shot
he was a leader of the military he they
he gave a coup d'etat you know
without any bloodshed the bloodshed came
of course
when we cuba decided that we didn't want
to be
a republic with a dictatorship
we wanted to to to be a republic
with a bad government or with a good
government
but elected by the people not a good
government we didn't want to have a bad
government or a good government
but fidel said it very clearly when he
was talking about
the why of the why we needed to get back
but it's out of power
because cuba was a republic and then we
had a president
that you elected and if you and you did
bad things
or good things and did not and then
and then you change to a new one you
have the ability to do good things or
bad things but there was a a rhythm
a constitutional rhythm and that is what
that fidel interrupted he preached that
he wanted to return cuba to that
situation
because it's beautiful to say you made a
mistake
you had a bad you elected a back
government or this government was bad
you had the power to change it and that
was the only that
was the biggest lie of fidel
that that he wanted to bring cuba back
to be self determining by the people
in what kind of situation we were who
was going to be depressing and
and all that but you know that that's uh
what happened
did you believe in infidel at the start
of the revolution
uh i did not believe in fidel uh
i i i
i knew that he was fighting
and a young person considers that you
have an idea
and you fight for it that that is that
is good
so i i i to to tell you
you know i have never a fanatic of
nobody
and when i said about trump you know
that that i respect him i am not a
fanatic of trump
and i think that trump did some major
mistakes
in how he talked to the press or how he
did it or how he do that
okay but but i have never been moved by
by following anybody my father
gave me a lesson one day and that was
during
what i did against batita
i am at the marriage brothers one day
and they tell me
in 1958 hey jose
we are not going to come to school
tomorrow
why no it's going to be a general a
general strike
against batita so i said
fine how is this okay go we come in the
morning
we go to to this to the first class for
two hours when we go to the recreation
to the
jerusalem recreation when you go to
recreation
you come back you come back to to the
salon
get your books and go home
and i did that there were 500 students
there
half the lower grades and half of the
secondary so
i get my books i start walking towards a
green gate at the end of the
of the of the campus there was a
baseball camp
i go over there where we all go and the
bosses go out
and when i look back i see only one
student behind me
joaquin badel i remember his name
it happens that joaquin bader was the
son
of a baptista uh functionary
that he had a his father had a good job
during the batteta regime
i know because he lived in my
neighborhood and when you walk by his
house
a a large open a large window was
open and you could see a painted
painted thing of batita a general you
know a nice painting of batita so
i i know that he was for batita
that was the only kid that followed me a
guy that would get in trouble with his
father
because his father were like what do you
mean what are you joining what what a
strike are you joining against batita
so they call us
the next week they called my father at
me and said
uh this is not he said
the hermano hermano is is not a priest
it's a religious order and they are
called hermanos
not fathers no not fathers or whatever
so he said this school
is for learning this school is not to do
a strikes here
and and and i and i said well
uh but cuba
has a dictatorship
and it was not even my idea
here they told me it was going to happen
and i
just participated on it and then my
father ended up the meeting
and said nino
you did right but you did something
wrong
next time you do something know what
you're committed with
don't compete with people that are not
really committed
so you know the day that youngsters in
cuba in the future
can commit themselves to do something i
don't care it is right or wrong
but that they have the the integrity
to follow doing what they think if they
are wrong they will realize they are
wrong
but i think i did the right thing in
uh in committing myself to do something
and my father
only gave me a lesson be be sure that
you do it with the right people and this
is why
when i joined the org the the
underground
i realized that i was with that kind of
truth that was committed to the same
things that i was committed
to it's a great lesson there are a lot
of people who are mindlessly droning on
and just following whatever it is the
media says and they're putting out these
messages and young people just blindly
repeat it
but let's uh let's jump to super chats
and see what a lot of people probably
have questions we'll talk to the
audience if you haven't already give us
a like hit that like button
and subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends if you thought
these
uh warnings and stories were very
important and we're going to have a
members only podcast going up usually
around 11 or so pm tonight
after this show wraps up where we're
going to talk about the
censorship and uh other things that are
affecting this country because we're
certainly dealing with it so you'll want
to see that
but let's read some super chats all
right let's see here's a
totally off off topic because a lot of
people you know just want to ask
questions alexander
leonem says first super chat this is for
ian
trying to discuss the tabletop rpg
stream you and tim have discussed on
minds please get back to me when you can
we will uh make sure ian is aware i will
convey this to him
enlightened worm says tim please stop
saying san diego has a gop
mayor we lost him in november our new
mayor is a democrat aligning with our
progressive city council
he supports sb 145 and doubled his
salary while calling people that want to
work
selfish yes and that and that is a
absolutely fair point
so to clarify my previous comments and i
did mention this a few times
the data on san diego's mayor is is
outdated and the data on the crime stuff
was
from a while ago all right let's see
gc geek army this is important pot uh
this
important podcast will anger jimmy dore
he claims that cuba
is a cia operation do you think the
people that are rising up in protest is
a cia manipulated
no that that that is completely
false people
have rebelled out of uh
a situation that they they cannot live
under uh there are no cia people
talking to people in havana or in any
town
there are no americans there doing
anything
uh and and to say that is is uh
uh is covered
it is is a co-worker statement
because people even when i was
in the underground in acting city where
there were cia people in cuba
i never met one and none of my friends
met anyone i am sure they had contacted
maybe other organizations
but our own organization never had
contact with the cia
if the cia we didn't even know about the
invasion
but but listen listen if the cia is
actively trying to foment revolution
would that not be america
helping cuba of course
i think this whole ia talk i mean you
just have to look at the everyday life
of a cuban and what they've been living
for the past 62 years where
you know basically if you don't have
family outside of cuba
you're not going to survive like the
these cubans that that are still
on the island are getting a lot of
outside help from their their family
members that have left
they send them money back that's kind of
how they survive through their
day-to-day
and i think a lot of these cubans that
are rising up and protesting
maybe some of the ones that don't have
that outside help but they're just
fed up with trying to survive from day
to day and like my father said
you reach a breaking point at a certain
point where
you're denied your basic human rights
every day of your life uh
you're you're paid in a currency that
isn't valuable
to go out and buy things that you need
um when you do go out and get the things
you need you have to sit and wait in
line all day long
by the time you get there oh we don't
have any left you got to go to this
other place
you spend your whole life sitting around
waiting in line you you have no real
per you don't feel like you have a
purpose in life and they're sick of it
now so now they're they're finally
raising their voices against
their their oppressors which is bound to
happen sooner or later
all right we got james dorpinghouse says
the stream has only just begun but i
love it already god bless this man we
need more good americans like him to
speak out against communism
but you're cuban i thank you about but i
tell you
something the the citizenship is not in
the paper
and it's true that i have not become an
american citizen to remind me why i am
here
for aboriginal more american
uh and feel more american
that many people that really have this
certificate were born here
but by the conduct they are traitors to
this country
yes so you know i i really feel that i
that i am a soldier of this country and
i am willing
team believe me i am willing to die for
this country
any time okay with the same love and
passion
even though i don't feel happy with this
country sometimes
oh yeah but i am here and i am grateful
that i am here
and that i was able to raise a beautiful
family like my son ricardo and all my
kids
right now jr says as a cuban-born
american citizen i want to say thank you
tim for giving these men a voice
long live freedom yeah i saw that and
then i just i just thought of something
i'm like
you know you're telling me the story
about being in the in the in the
anti-castro underground in cuba
being chased by these soldiers trying to
sneak past them
and i'm like man this guy is a fighter
and his son is a fighter
quite literally i mean you can see that
apple doesn't fall
too far from the tree yeah there is
something you don't know my son
is very special in many ways
he's a a great son he is a spectacular
father
uh he's a great brother he has
he was a little kid very special
and uh all my sons are
are basically like that so i i am
i am i am very proud but there are many
things about
about ricardo that uh
that people don't know and that i
actually sometimes
i i get surprised that he has been
watching me
we we we had in chicago for
30 years a cuban picnic
and that cuban picnic when organizer
began to die
and the community became not a smaller
board more americanized
it was difficult to organize a big
activity where four or five thousand
cuba would show up
to have lunch with pork and rice and you
know
our things so that activity
that also served to raise funds for
their many cuban organizations that
would come together and organize it
disappear
and about 11 years ago
a young cuban half cuban a young person
decides to organize using the old name
that we have
fetival cubano as an activity but
different
not with the purpose of bringing
together humans
to remind us of our culture and our
duties and to make
a contribution but he did it to raise
money
okay he was a an entrepreneur involved
in in other festivals and he thought
wait a minute the cuban music oh
let's let's do the cuban festival
but you could not say there
abajo nope no political
talks at a cuban festival oh wow about
cuba that's being oppressed by a
dictatorship
like wow okay so the way we realize
about this is because i was doing a
promotion for
for ricardo and uh and and one of the
sponsors of ricardo a jewelry store
asked me jose could ricardo come
to my table to my area in the festival
to my tent and be there signing
posters and letting people take pictures
say yes
and then they invited us to go
and i know i said i want to introduce my
son in this stage
so i went to the stage introduced
ricardo and said viva kuvaliri
and behind me where it was the vip area
i heard like something strange here
so ricardo spoke and he said vivacoga
and the same reaction happened so in a
human festival where you cannot say biba
cuba
i realize and that and that means for
those that don't speak spanish
long live free cuba okay i realize
we need to pick it next year festival
and i spent about a week
in my he he used to live with us
in his home with us in how do you call
that the second floor
it's like that it's like it's like an
attic like this up here you know
yeah attic room um and we had a
una calera de caracol
yeah the spiral spiral yeah so he will
he will
pass by my area where i had my desk
where i was working in some flyers
trying to come up with a propaganda
thing
to distribute there and he every night
that he sees me working there he looks
at me
and then he goes up then the friday that
i decide
the friday that i started that festival
i i had about ten thousand flyers that i
was going to go and distribute there
himself he was going to go back showing
showing
a picture of almorzo campetri
on or a banner that the same name that
these people were using
in one of the uh uh in one of the latest
fed cuban festivals and and i said
this is truly the real cuban festival
and then we we describe the purposes of
what we were doing
at that time and what this festival was
and
my intention was which i did to
distribute there but i didn't know
when i on friday when i am gonna walk
out of my house
ricardo comes down and says where are
you going dad
i said well uh rika you know i'm gonna
detour the flight you're okay fine
and then he went with me and he was my
security
and then since since i am
very well known in chicago we
we distribute all these flyers right but
i
there was an area that i wanted to enter
it was the vip area where the vips
that were behind the stage had their
cars okay
there were a hundred cars okay
so i approached the uh the the security
people that were there
and i show them the the the flyer and
they say effective alcohol
and say look i have been distributing
this in the front
i would like to put it in the car they
say oh fatigue so they didn't really
so we went there and in all the cars we
we put these things
and next you know next i know is
they were very much upset at the next
factor i couldn't do pull the same trick
but then what we did is instead of
keeping
uh you know going there to distribute
fliers
we organize again they truly
cuban festival and we could not do it
last year because of kobe
oh yeah it was suspended but but will
this year we probably won't be able to
do it because it takes too much time but
but there there might be lockdowns
coming again as well i mean mitch
mcconnell just said
you know get vaccinated or the lockdowns
are coming so geez yeah we'll see
let's uh so ricardo has played an
important role
on all my family my kids in in my
in me being able to feel good in doing
things because
they support me they have always done it
very nice
let's read some more we got trash panda
he says i've heard similar horror
stories from the soviet union
mr lamas have you considered testifying
to congress or making videos talking
about communism
well i don't think that i need to go to
35 in congress i think that
americans should learn more about what
already had been testified in congress
and and this brings me to the qm program
in in the zoo in hanoi
there were 17 prisoners american
prisoners
in this torture center
or program and that program was called
the q1 program the main tortures there
there were three cubans the prisoners
themselves designated one of them with
the name of
fidel because was the worst of them
the most savage okay and these prisoners
were tortured and
and you know harry seikon
they were uh they they were tortured
with
with physical tortures like
like pulleys from trucks across their
butt
and their face and there were 17
prisoners these three queues of the q1
program
were able to break all those
except one
that was a navy that was
a a pilot that was down
this pilot that was down uh
developed some brain trauma
and the and this torturous thought
or or wanted to believe that he was
acting up
so he wouldn't be tortured
and then they sat him on a chair and a
prisoner saw it from his cell
when fidel with a big rubber sheet from
a truck
and smash this guy on his face
he did not blink he did not cry
he was in catatonic state
do americans need that i go
to testify about anything when there are
information like this
that this happened to 17 american
soldiers
and this country didn't react to that
i i can go to congress but number one is
going to be
the guy of course there will be a
translator there and people
won't go have to won't have to go as
crazy as those people listening now
trying to understand
what i'm saying because when i when i
get
to emotional topics my
my my my spanish culture and my spanish
language
permeates my brain and and even
mutilates
more my my good command my command of
the english language
when i when i get into emotional topics
because
is what happens is when you are speaking
your language
you really feel what you are saying and
when you say in your in
in you a foreign language a dirty word
you don't even think it's a dirty word
so
when i talk about this i know it's hard
to understand me
but i i have a message
for the american people try to research
the information that was hearing from
you
try to understand that this country is
as a crew
as a crossroads
principles ideals
love for the country forget about those
revolutionary ideas that only destroy
what you could have
what you already have you know progress
is a continuous effort is this
is not a now
to to five minutes from now a huge
jump okay all these people want power
and and they are gonna they are
destroying your country
this is the greatest country in the
world yeah
yeah absolutely all right cereal says my
father
my father had me read against all hope
by armando valadares
in middle school it details his
experience in castro's political prison
in gulags
i'd love to know if this gentleman can
confirm the horrors in that book
of of course and actually for his
information
we brought his wife marta valladares to
chicago
okay and we pay tribute to bayadare
through his wife
and yes everything that amando ayala
wrote including another book
the the messiah some people say that he
pretended to be paralyzed okay
and he bought he wrote poems and uh
he wrote that book and everything that
is in the book is true
and and the problem is that is hard to
understand
and how to write when somebody stands in
front of of defining a squad
and night by night you hear say them
saying
[Music]
and you feel the chats of the squad and
then you feed the solitary shots on his
head
how can you describe that night by night
throughout cuba so
yes armando ayares is
an uh actually he he became uh
ambassador
of cuba of the united states i think too
yeah all right hayden says thank you
guys for coming on tonight
it's great to hear the real story of
cuba what can the average american do to
help cuba
petitioning our government isn't having
much effect anymore what can we do to
stop the us from failing that way i'd
love your perspective
i think um you know
getting the cubans message out number
one um
the the regime is constantly cutting off
electricity shutting down the wi-fi for
the cubans to kind of get these videos
out
so the ones that are circulating to keep
circulating them
um you know me and my father also raise
money to
to try and help out with these groups
that are opposing the regime we've we've
raised money we've sent to cuban
dissidents
um we've sent it to other uh
groups like the ladies in white is is
another famous group in cuba who
non-violently protests for the release
of political prisoners
and their uh daily you know every time
they go to protest they're beaten
um they're they're physically harassed
in the streets
um so if if they would like to
contribute you know
they can get a hold of me and and we can
we can set up something to do that
uh although i tried setting up like a
gofundme page or whatever but because of
the sanctions the u.s has on cuba
when i mentioned the word cuba they shut
down the page so wow
all the money that i've raised i've
raised by hand through my social media
pages
and then through contacts that my father
has we were able to get
money into cuba to cuban dissidents to
help them out
all right let's see what we got here
grab boyd biden says sounds like he is
talking about the modern day fbi
makes me sad to see this country
repeating the worst parts of history
absolutely all right let's see where are
we at
kisham says not surprising that castro
set up or supported purported events as
cover to arrest those opposing him
doesn't sound familiar at all well there
you go
all right let's see a lot of people just
saying thank you for coming which is
which is fantastic
vladimir vutin says this man is a master
storyteller keep going sir thank you
have you uh have you written a book
about it or anything no no
we've pushed him for years and years to
at least get a story down
um you know i've heard it throughout my
life in bits and pieces but i've never
been able to like chronologically put it
together
and i think that's that's an important
part um and i mean i've
we've tried everything i've even bought
him a tape recorder
the old school tape recorder because i i
knew he wouldn't know how to
you know uh handle like a digital one
with the tapes and all that
but i think you know you definitely have
to sit down and get your story out on
tape and we go from there
definitely maybe maybe get a ghost
writer somebody just you just tell the
story to them and they write it down as
you talk
and that would be one of us one of his
sons and it would drive us
it man dude probably crazy least 10
years just continuously writing do it on
video when you do
so it can they can record you telling
the story yeah
as well as the writing yeah harito says
i love this episode it's mind-blowing
thank you
thank you for the super chat this is
funny i saw this one earlier
sermon fable says goobers in the chat
keep saying lol tim is so quiet today
when if i were in his position i would
have 100
focus on everything this kind gentleman
has to say some of y'all don't realize
he's trying to warn us this is this is
the point
we have somebody who's experienced the
authoritarian communist revolution
and we need to pay attention to those
who have experience
in this area uh i'll tell you man there
have been
there have been conversations um
for a while now among people i know
like other people who are who are
political activists other people who are
journalists
not necessarily to say that we're at the
point where the u.s has fallen in we
have to flee into exile or anything like
that
but clearly with the level of political
tumult in this country and the divide
the conversations have come up where
people say when is that point
when you think the u.s is too far gone
and you need to leave i mean just just
for context
joe biden said that the
the republican voting bills are the
greatest threat to this country since
the civil war
as if you know we have these we have the
republicans trying to pass
uh voter reform laws as well as and the
democrats trying to pass complete voter
overhaul hr one
both of which are viewed by the other
side as the apocalypse
and i happen to think hr one is bad i
fall on the side where i think the
republicans are at least doing something
that they're not doing enough
to say that the republicans pushing
a a moderate bill is the greatest threat
since the civil war i mean it sounds
like we're getting to this very
dangerous point with the capitol police
setting up national offices we're
getting to the dangerous point
and so i guess there's a question of you
know how do you know when things are too
far gone and you just leave you have to
get out
with jose is there something you think
could have been done differently between
1958 and 1961 that would have prevented
yes what yes uh
we we should of allow
batista he was going to have to be out
in the other elections
let's say that batita would have
committed fraud
in the elections but after that
probably another regime will come
another president
and we could of slowly get out of it
when when fidel took the opportunity and
precipitated the revolution he was only
looking not for resolution he was
looking for him
to be the guy in charge after batita
left
and he needed to create a convulsion to
to them to control it
i i think that we should of
peacefully try
to manage this situation because we but
it had not destroyed the press
but it had not destroyed the
institutions of cuba
the political institutions and the civic
institutions and
and all the other institutions of cuba
or
good organizations he had not touched
these
the social a standard of cured economic
standard of cuba to the contrary he
continued going
and we made the mistake of
trying to come up with
a drastic change
whether it's good or bad sometimes those
changes do not work
because they don't have nothing
preceding that will allow you to
to continue in one direction upward
okay those changes are not good so if we
would have been more patient
if we would have been if we would have
been listening to
the revolutionary spirit you know that
fidel tried to convey
we could have we could have uh not
entered these attacks and never ending
at age
never ending change beau raicho
wins says this needs to go viral well
if you think so then it's just incumbent
upon you to share it
that's what makes things go viral so it
would be fantastic i mean
i think you know you've basically been
telling your story and your experiences
and i'm i'm just wrapped up in listening
to these stories
because they're so important and i think
for everybody who's listening if you
agree and you're and you think people
need to share
hear this then absolutely please share
this
julie simone says thank you senor lamas
for sharing your story
we should listen to more people who
understand what it is to not not to be
free
to truly appreciate why why we are so
lucky
and should keep up the freedom fight
absolutely yeah
here's something interesting and and
totally uh off topic ponyboy says if you
go
full screen mode on timcast.com then
swipe out
you can listen to the podcast while
browsing your phone or while your screen
is off
is that the uh i'll we'll try that later
i guess that's the
that's the non-app hack for listening to
the podcast i suppose
all right let's see mr lista says my
cuban refugee grandfather used to tell
me these same horror stories
they sounded fictional till 2020. thanks
for sharing your brilliant father
coach rick there you go is that what is
that people call you
what was oh no he might be a member of
my gym then mr
glista okay yeah yeah matt i think
that's matt
what's up man how you doing man right
now
all right josiah
uh let's see oh wait no okay okay i
can't read that one
um all right
michael volpe says because of jfk's
failure to support the cuban people in
62
is that the reason most cubans vote
republican
do cubans vote republican yeah i think
for the most part yeah
is it because democrats are commies i
think they start
i think that's what they see you know
and that's why they're they're
more republican and a lot of these old
cubans are more conservative too so
they're
kind of it kind of freaks me out when
you have people who actually fled a
communist dictatorship being like
i'm going to avoid those people because
they're communists i'm like oh
they're telling us something they see
the warning signs already and the rest
of america isn't paying attention yeah i
really i really think that's the reason
alejandro mallorca said that cubans
would not be welcomed into the u.s
cubans and haitians because they tend to
vote conservatively
oh yeah i think it's entirely political
it was amazing that
at southern border they're you know
bringing kids in they're shipping them
on planes they're flying around
and then you've got this crisis
happening in cuba and they're like let
us be clear if you try and come we're
going to send you away
that that refers to cubans and haitians
right
right you know is discriminatory
and is actually a crazy
he's a statement i'm not saying that
he's crazy
but this statement is crazy how do what
do you mean
when you say that if you come by sea
you are not going to reach the united
states
so colon have would never reach the the
hemisphere right
yeah by sea why what is the problem with
cubans
taking to the sea seeking for freedom
they're anti-communists well
when you have people coming from with
the with the with the border crisis
in the u.s we've had stories of people
from africa flying to brazil and then
traveling up to the southern border of
mexico
these are people who are not fleeing
political persecution they've brazil is
amazing
if they've made it to brazil i love
brazil i've been to rio and sao paulo
and they're both just absolutely amazing
rio wow
so people on vacation there but to leave
these places come to america i get it
america is awesome
but then you have actual cubans who are
desperately trying to build rafts to
escape
political persecution torture
imprisonment and they're like nana you
get sent away they don't care about
refugees
imagine how bad your life has to be to
to risk your life by boarding just a
man-made raft
to try and float 90 miles across open
ocean and cubans have done this
with their children you know i don't
know i don't know if you remember in the
90s but there was a
little boy that yeah washed up on shore
elian gonzalez and his mother did not
make the trip
right she died on the way uh america
intervened for that
to give elian back you know to cuba i
i've said this about the the border
crisis of the u.s
every single one of these refugees who
are fleeing political persecution should
be granted
asylum the issue is that most of them
the overwhelming majority are not
actually doing that
it's like i think you know something
like 95 plus percent they end up finding
out it's just people who want to
they're economic migrants they want a
job they want to come here uh the famous
interview was where someone said i miss
buffalo wild wings it's like
i get it man i love me some b-dubs but
when i see people who are like
if i if i stay in mexico the cartels
will kill me and i'm like
we can't condemn these people and i
understand it's not a perfect solution a
lot of people probably are not a fan of
you know america being this place where
we're going to bring everybody in for
asylum
but at least in close proximity the
country i can recognize that if
someone's in
you know guatemala or honduras well
mexico is right there
if someone is in cuba florida is right
there yeah so
it's very very different for cuban
refugees trying to escape
compared to people in south america
trying to come up through all these
different countries and ignoring them
but uh let's let's do this we're i want
to go to the um
the members podcast so if you haven't
already hit that like button subscribe
to this channel go to timcast.com become
a member
as a member you get at an ad free
experience you are helping support our
journalists that we've now
hired very many and very many more and
you'll get access to these members
podcast we're going to talk about
censorship and get more into the details
and uh show you know what was going on
and talk about a little bit what
happened earlier with your guys's
t-shirt
so again teamcast.com you can follow the
show at timcast irl on facebook and
instagram
at tim cast underscore irl on tick tock
you can follow me personally at tim cast
do you guys have a website or any social
media or anything you want to shout out
uh yeah people can uh follow me on
instagram and twitter
at ricardo llamas mma and that's where i
do most of my fundraising work is is
through those social media platforms
um on facebook you can follow my dad's
group uh
chicago um so you can uh you can find
hit the the link to that
on on my fan page also i will leave in
this
broadcast now i will
this will be the end of the live version
okay and then we'll do
can i can i mention that this coming
saturday
oh yeah yeah we have a an activity
in support of the cuban people
that that is going to be
bringing together or latin american
residents of the city
that are willing to voice
in behalf of the cuban people decry the
cry for freedom they cry for freedom and
we would like
them to know that we are expecting them
to
come and support us that will that
will be at the uh humble park monument
uh where the eagle is logan
logan square monument at 11 a.m this
coming saturday
is a
of dignity you know and i'll mention
something too uh just in our
demographics the
the the um most populous area
in terms of our viewership of the people
who watch the show
the largest percentage live in chicago
great for whatever reason i don't know
i'm from chicago and i guess we have
similar opinions chicago people
ian lived in chicago sheamus was on the
show is an illinois boy jack murphy it's
just right maybe it's just we're just
chicago kind of people but uh that guy's
been it's been a blast thanks for coming
we'll obviously go to that and by the
way when i say
when i said latin american if because
we're trying
that is a community where there were
many hispanic americans now that are
other
nationalities including of course the
americans
but we need the presence of the american
student yeah
and that's why our call has been done in
english and in spanish
on saturday we're all cuban right on the
slogan
hey you can follow me in crosstalk i was
just thinking about it yes
well why do you say we are all como city
say we are all cuban and espanol
todos somos cubanos toros
i love you guys both thank you guys for
coming thank you so much thank you very
much
i hope that you guys can see now why i
love my older people
they have something that younger people
do not have and we really need to learn
from them so i'm so glad that jose could
come and speak to us tonight and share
his story
you guys can follow me on twitter at
sarah patchoulits as i attempt to gain
more followers and sour patch kids
right on and you didn't mention your
your twitter oh it doesn't even matter
it's ian crossing
all right everybody uh go to timcast.com
for the members only podcast we're gonna
address some of the censorship issues
and talk about what's happening in this
country
thanks for hanging out we'll see you all
there
you